sadness is part of the human experience
but for centuries there has been vast
disagreement over exactly what it is and
what if anything to do about it in its
simplest terms
sadness is often thought of as the
natural reaction to a difficult
situation you feel sad when a friend
moves away or when a pet dies when a
friend says I'm sad you often respond by
asking what happened but your assumption
that sadness has an external cause
outside the self is a relatively new
idea ancient Greek doctors didn't view
sadness that way they believed it was a
dark fluid inside the body according to
their humoral system the human body and
soul were controlled by four fluids
known as humors and they're balanced
directly influenced a person's health
and temperament melancholia comes from
Malaya Nicoli the word for black bile
the humor believed to cause sadness by
changing your diet and through medical
practices you could bring your humors
into balance even though we now know
much more about the systems that govern
the human body these Greek ideas about
sadness resonate with current views not
on the sadness we all occasionally feel
but on clinical depression doctors
believe that certain kinds of long-term
unexplained emotional states are at
least partially related to brain
chemistry the balance of various
chemicals present inside the brain like
the Greek system changing the balance of
these chemicals can deeply alter how we
respond to even extremely difficult
circumstances there's also a long
tradition of attempting to discern the
value of sadness and in that discussion
you'll find a strong argument that
sadness is not only an inevitable part
of life but an essential one if you've
never felt melancholy you've missed out
on part of what it means to be human
many thinkers contend that melancholy is
necessary in gaining wisdom Robert
Burton born in 1577 spent his life
studying the causes and experience of
sadness in his masterpiece the anatomy
of melon
Holle Burton wrote he that increaseth
wisdom increases sorrow the Romantic
poets of the early 19th century believed
melancholy allows us to more deeply
understand other profound emotions like
beauty and joy to understand the sadness
of the trees losing their leaves in the
fall is to more fully understand the
cycle of life that brings flowers in the
spring but wisdom and emotional
intelligence seem pretty high on the
hierarchy of needs does sadness have
value on a more basic tangible maybe
even evolutionary level scientists think
that crying and feeling withdrawn is
what originally helped our ancestors
secure social bonds and help them get
the support they needed sadness as
opposed to anger or violence was an
expression of suffering that could
immediately bring people closer to the
suffering person and this helped both
the person and the larger community to
thrive
perhaps sadness helped generate the
unity we needed to survive but many have
wondered whether the suffering felt by
others is anything like the suffering we
experience ourselves the poet Emily
Dickinson wrote I measure every grief I
meet with narrow probing eyes I wonder
if it weighs like mine or has an easier
size and in the 20th century medical
anthropologists like Arthur Kleinman
gathered evidence from the way people
talk about pain to suggest that emotions
aren't universal at all and that culture
particularly the way we use language can
influence how we feel when we talk about
heartbreak the feeling of brokenness
becomes part of our experience whereas
in a culture that talks about a bruised
heart there actually seems to be a
different subjective experience some
contemporary thinkers are interested in
sadnesses subjectivity versus
universality and would rather use
technology to eliminate suffering in all
its forms David Pierce has suggested
that genetic engineering and other
contemporary processes can not only
alter the way humans experience
emotional and physical pain but that
world ecosystems ought to be redesigned
so that animals don't suffer in the wild
he calls his project Paradise
Engineering but is there something sad
about a world without sadness our
cavemen ancestors and favorite poets
might not want any part of such a
paradise in fact the only things about
sadness that seem universally agreed
upon are that it has been felt by most
people throughout time and that for
thousands of years one of the best ways
we have to deal with this difficult
emotion is to articulate it to try to
express what feels inexpressible in the
words of Emily Dickinson hope is the
thing with feathers that perches in the
soul and sings the tune without the
words and never stops at all